[Musik]
ein richtiger ist das stück fleisch
ich glaube viel wichtiger war schloss
haben ich finde es ist für die
schwächeren und stark machen
das ist das macht er richtig einmal
richtige maßstab für die schwachen und
bietet seine tools und eigentlich ist
einer der veganer der richtige maßstab
gemacht
[Musik]
daniel wyss das beste ist aus kunstleder
er und seine frau corinna leben seit
fünf jahren vegan
das heißt ohne tierische produkte nutzt
hier ist ein unwort für sie
[Musik]
warum also fleisch wir sind dir das sind
aber was man möchte nicht für tod von
analoger weise verantwortlich sie aber
der mensch hätte schon immer der ganze
wieso soll das liegt dann hätte ich das
schon immer klar aber kalt das macht
dann als eine die warum es immer gemacht
war da nicht warum das seit gut
[Musik]
schätzungsweise ein halbes bis ein
prozent der schweizer bevölkerung lebt
vegan
veganer verzichten aus ethischen
ökologischen und gesundheitlichen
gründen auf alle tierischen produkte um
sie herum hat sich in den letzten jahren
eine neue veganer konsum welt entwickelt
[Musik]
als veganerin ist corinna pfister
selbstverständlich kein fleisch auch
milch und milchprodukte sowie sämtliche
lebensmittel die milchpulver butter rahm
käse oder milch schokolade enthalten
bleiben im regal
eier sind tabu genau wie alle
lebensmittel die eier oder ein pulver
enthalten
wenn eine allergie hat wegen der lage
ist muss man am anfang jahr gegen die
umstellung aufwand betrieben was das
darf nicht so in fleisch und blut über
vor fünf jahren nach einer kurzen
vegetarischen episode haben sich daniel
pfister und seine frau corinna
entschieden wird an vegan zu leben
corinna fischer arbeitet als
kaufmännische angestellte bei einer
versicherung ihr mann daniel ist
gelernte sanitärinstallateur
sein ersatz für mayonnaise das noch im
mittelmaß und mitsamt also dauern medica
marion ansonsten und trotzdem man nicht
sowieso eine französische schiesser
macht was ich leute kaufen das geht noch
heute stehen bei pfisters linsen mit
gemüse und kartoffeln mit einem
sogenannten hefe schmelz auf dem
menüplan hochdosierte pflanzliche
proteine möglichkeit der stadt ja dass
wir uns aber es ist ja alles astrein
fleischers und in der heutigen zeit ist
das problem dass ab und zu mal fleisch
wieder mal gesagt jetzt einmal war
vielleicht weniger des großes problem
es war logische gründe haben großes
problem jahres gesundheitlich und
notizen sind für die heutzutage mir
unsere kalorienbedarf lockert es
pflanzliche nahrungsmittel also ist das
ganze land war hinter der
fleischproduktion steht nötig machen uns
ganz gut
es ist problemlos gesund möglich
natürlich wären harnik aber das ist
problemlos möglich
auch tochter melina wird vegan ernährt
dies entgegen der empfehlung der
schweizerischen gesellschaft für
pädiatrie und des bundesamtes für
gesundheit das lebensnotwendige vitamin
b12 das ausschließlich in fleisch eiern
und milchprodukten vorkommt erhält
melinda ins pre form genau wie
zusätzliches vitamin d das bekommen auch
alle nicht vegan ernährten babys
wir sind ok wenn man noch nie schlagen
könnt ja nicht per se empfiehlt oder
wenn es einen fehlt dann hat einfacher
sein wenn man merkt ja schlussendlich
bin ich überzeugt davon dass mein kind
vom anderem fleisch asse nicht so
wirklich exakt dort bewohnt wird bei uns
wo wir einfach noch mal böse mit mir in
der klemme
vielmehr halte frau im fokus stand mit
unserer regionalliga so viel glück haben
unsere yards die nur nach lima bei
unserem kind um ihr uns aber auch
explizit meter als nötig war
will mir gewarnt sich sie und bremer ich
danke oliver sophie hindermann gibt sind
immer da so verlag wo ein sehr am herzen
liegt und vor dem halt in ihrem kind
nicht mehr bezwingen
als andere ältere also machen wir doch
nicht anders aber sieht zudem tierische
produkte quasi vorenthalten niemandem
vorenthalten wie das an die eltern
also mir finde jetzt einfach fleisch
finden wir die schlacht ist auch
fleischesser finde gut dass auch wir
finden oder auch nur die sache und man
viel alkohol gut ist auch unser system
an unserem kind vorenthalten
[Musik]
und warum es ihnen nicht ausreicht
vegetarisch zu leben zeigen daniel und
corinna pfister anhand eines videos zur
eierproduktion zweieinhalb millionen
eintagsküken fallen pro jahr allein in
der schweiz an
unabhängig davon ob es sich um bio oder
um konventionell produzierte eier handel
sie legen keine eier und lassen sich
nichts und polizisten weil die rasse nur
fürs eierlegen gezüchtet ist die ihre
stunden sind gezählt
kurz nach dem schlüpfen werden die
menschen weg geschafft in die gaskammer
das kohlendioxid strömt ein
die tiere verstecken
sie schicken
sie kann von der veganen welle leben
laurin wildbolz vegane kirchen
künstlerin kochbuch autorin ehemaliges
model und bloggerin
im jahre 2010 eröffnete sie das erste
vegane restaurant in zürich heute
bekocht sie die stadt mit ihrem veganen
catering
[Musik]
der wendepunkt ist von circa 7
ich praktiziere seiner stange yoga und
nach einem yoga und ist ein riese milch
und betrunken
was ist eine milchkaffee und der hat
eine menge energie wirklich im boden
aber was ich jetzt schon wieder los und
ich bin süchtig nach den milchkaffee am
morgen und hatten einfach anstatt
manchmal half men christmas probiert was
extrem lecker ist und haben gesagt okay
ich mache zu experimenten sich jetzt
wegen nachdem schmeckt dann wir mit
rainer wird wenn ich mich fitter wird -
politiker und mittlerweile lebt laurin
wildbolz komplett ohne tierische
produkte mit dem kupfer wolle passt
image das veganern ihrer meinung nach
anhaftet will sie aufräumen
deshalb lässt sie sich für diese
dreharbeiten schminken vegan natürlich
zum beispiel beliebte stift hat es oft
die richterin
wie zum beispiel walfisch fett oder
lanolin also sowohl was für die chance
dann könnte aber auch ford big band dear
ich sehe wie kamin
es kann wie sehr günstige kosmetik also
gesichtscreme zum beispiel bodylotion
hast du gar wie schlachtabfälle trieben
habe also nicht nur begrenzt es gibt
auch edel marke wo zum strecke mit dem
inhaltsstoff schaffte versus bienenwachs
milch und honig in der gesichtsmaske
völlig inakzeptabel für die konsequente
veganerin total extrem denkt da der
alles esse
vielleicht die stimmige einiges mehr
extrem was ich machen muss oder macht
als ich komm ich jetzt damit frische
bilder fassen für sie zusammen
bis kurz damit hoch aber ich glaube nur
klare haltung und mit
[Musik]
die vegane lebensweise ist in der
gesellschaft angekommen
davon ist lauren wildbolz überzeugt ihre
doch kurse jedenfalls sind regelmäßig
ausgebucht
[Musik]
der noch aus
also wenn es natürlich nicht vor -
prozent die gewalt so ja ein verbot wie
mächtig das natürlich ein eigenes stück
land in der schweiz geschlachtet worden
nicht aber natürlich nur der ökobilanz
nachhaltige ob ich mich schon sehr dass
sich regional und saisonal hoffen
jetzt führt hoch große sache ist die
avocado für das spezifisch ich hab immer
zwei will meistens einige schlachten
avocado britta lüth
also bietet eigentlich ursprünglich aus
den tropischen 50 höchstens man in summe
immer wieder sagt mir die hand fühlen
die wirkung auf den körper warum aus der
tropische durch rein winter benutzer was
es macht schon sinn regional die vegane
küche eine geschmacksexplosion sagt
lauren wildbolz ihre zutaten sind
frischprodukte und elemente aus der
asiatischen küche convenience und
fertigprodukte so wenig wie möglich
über innere von berti vielfältig egal wo
ich so alternativ produkten sollte jetzt
system so charmant wie zu lesen und
durchsuchen bringen sind
als ich zurück ganz so positiv dass wenn
die castoren oder regionen erik wevers
omega fiel nach mx produkt ist das im
leben viel weniger von dem ganzen
convenience food ist wendet über alle
völker und welches milch berufe drin ist
und also ab in der man liest was der
alles drin ist dann wird man sowieso hat
jetzt auch begonnen und chemisch werden
sie im kabinett so für ihre berufe wie
klicks um die amerikaner problematische
seite für mich schauen mehr wahr dass
ich eben mal einfach so und frisch ist
und das ganze verpackte zu dann ziehen
das widerruf und die klubschule der
micro bietet schweizweit seit zwei
jahren vegane kochkurse an und hat das
angebot in den letzten monaten aufgrund
der großen nachfrage stark erweitert und
die tegra wenig krieg das schon sehr so
ein rückschlag
[Musik]
einmal im jahr wird winterthur zum mekka
der veganen szene
dann herrscht viel wiegen mini
[Musik]
kollege gaben die städtischen
klassisches für das la paz vega wird für
mich stimmt meinte dass wir mit dem
ergebnis mit dezember bis kurz ist gut
für haben wird die veganer und veganerin
und tragen keine wolle keine seite keine
daunen und kein leder
es geht natürlich will ich irgendwann
das eigentlich
sogar baumwoll t shirts können vegan
sein sind sie auch menschen damit
verbunden die ja auch tiere sind also
sollte tiere im dass die halt eben auch
gerecht bezahlt und behandelt werden
also was das thema angeht und was die
botschaft angeht wenn sie die t shirts
gesehen haben
wir haben schon ein bisschen spaß
charakter und und veganes leben soll
auch spaß machen und nicht nur schimpfen
und zeigefinger zeigen sondern einfach
auch freude bereiten
[Musik]
die beiden veganen organisationen die
vegane gesellschaft schweiz und swiss
weg erhalten zulauf vornehmlich aus der
jüngeren generation
die vegane lebensweise ist vor allem bei
jungen gut ausgebildeten frauen im trend
neben pflanzlichen cancer werden an der
wige media auch fleisch und wurst
alternativen angeboten
warum bloß wo man doch so vehement gegen
fleischkonsum ist
entscheidet man sich ein bisschen was
machen wir zwischen vergangen warte aber
bekennt sich genau gleich mit recht
stabil verbracht oder mit chicken
nuggets und die art von produkt
ermöglichen dass nach wie vor ohne
tierleid
[Musik]
berlin da die tochter von daniel und
corina pfister besucht eine krippe in
der man auf ihre vegane ernährungsweise
rücksicht nimmt
melinda ist gemeinsam mit den anderen
kindern wenn es fleisch eier oder
geburtstagskuchen mit butter und eiern
gibt bekommt melinda eine vegane
alternative welche die eltern in der
krippe deponiert haben
[Musik]
also eines ist sicher prinzips auch wenn
wir mehr nach und vergaben möchten und
regionale und des spieles carol oates
das rind ich denn wird dass veganer
nacht und andere ist es möglich für sie
gar keine produkte tragen weil sie sich
gar nicht gewöhnt hat menschen für sich
video wenn er aufgestellt ist und die
mögliche produkt gewöhnt und eine
verbreitung körper das wär halt einfach
nur sinn wenn der körper es nicht wohnt
sieht es da ganz oben trifft reagiert
sie hätte jetzt sicher schon ein etwas
andere ins milch steckt und natürlich
auch nicht der gewalt unter den wagen
und franziska mit dem rad aber es wird
ihnen wahrscheinlich schwarzfahrer mit
dem pfarrbüro es wirklich liebe also
wenn sie irgendwann erwachsen zeit
machen ich will jetzt auf live ist das
auch live aber dass ich ihren entscheid
denn doch einem er an i mach ich habe
mich einfach in andere wagen zu der mini
er respektiere dass die vegane ernährung
von säuglingen und kleinkindern birgt
einige gefahren
lebensbedrohlich kann es für ein kind
werden wenn eine veganerin schon in der
schwangerschaft einen mangel an vitamin
b12 hat corinna fischer informierte sich
deshalb ausführlich über die risiken und
führt er sich stets ausreichend vitamin
b12 zu nicht alle vegan lebenden eltern
handeln so umsichtig am ostschweizer
kinderspital in st gallen wurden in den
letzten jahren vegan ernährten kinder
behandelt denen kein zusätzliches
vitamin b12 verabreicht wurde
ungenügende gewichtszunahme motorische
defizite und diverse mangelerscheinungen
waren die symptome
es braucht für eine eine kleinkind
ernährung mit mit ausschließlich veganer
kost braucht es ein netzwerk von
ernährungsberatern kinderärzte darum
wessen die bescheid wissen was es
braucht und ein so gutes
vertrauensverhältnis auch zu den
familien haben dass man das gemeinsam
durch zieht ich denke wenn man das macht
dann geht es gut ich würde davor waren
es zu dogmatisch im kindesalter zu sehen
die vermittlung eines gesunden
lebensstil sollte meines erachtens
positiv besetzt sein
ich weiß was gut für mich ist und nicht
so sehr das andere ist böse
zum beispiel wenn sie erleben dass ihre
guten freunde ganz normal abends 1 1 ein
stück fleisch essen und sie haben im
hinterkopf dass man ihr gesagt das
fleisch ist böse oder das fleisch ist
schlecht und der beste freund macht das
da ist ein widerspruch dass das kind
eigentlich nicht wirklich verstehen kann
und dann kommen sie zurück zu ihren
eltern und erfahren ihr habt dieses
dieses dieser lebensstil ist schlecht
für dich und das ist etwas was so nicht
erwiesen ist dann schlecht ist nicht an
gelegentlichen stück fleisch oder fisch
oder politisch überhaupt nicht schlecht
schlecht ist die art und weise wie
fleisch produziert wird schlecht ist die
menge an fleisch diebe zu uns nehmen
aber nicht grundsätzlich das fleisch an
und für sich
und ich mal zu meiner mutter bin ist das
gras vor dem stall hohe skulptur und das
carl ganzen gerade weg no und ihnen
installieren und die hohe die hat so
gern weil es kalt abschlag die hat so
viel schlimmes modus als einfach am
boden offen ist und sie haben möchtet
und gemacht und da sich herz erweichen
sie und ich hatte pulpo ist dass sie und
der bruder gesagt ja wir waren ja da
silva auch wenn die heute ihre kälber
zum teil abdecken dürfen die kuh und ihr
kalb werden in der regel unmittelbar
nach der geburt getrennt nach dem
abkalben ginge die milchproduktion einer
kuh natürlicherweise bald zurück um dies
zu verhindern wird eine milchkuh acht
bis zwölf wochen nach einer geburt
wieder neu besand alle zwölf bis
vierzehn monate bringt sie so ein kalb
zur welt mit sechs bis sieben jahren
wird eine kuh meist nicht mehr trächtig
und kommt ins schlachthaus wie die
männlichen kälber die mit etwa
fünfeinhalb monaten schlachtreif sind
[Musik]
19 mann der jungen alten anlagen wie das
unsinnige wissen um mit toilette und
happy und sich ausdrückt mit dem ganzen
körper ist wie schön dass es für mich
dann begriffe sind auch der unterschied
wenn sich das gleiche weise wie meine
spielerinnen und die starker
lärmbelastung gewinnen und die gedanken
muss sie wo überhaupt nichts das in
weseke und warum machen mit aus wie mir
meine tiere so hatte damit mehr könnt
äußern einer von ihnen
und das ist einfach als völlig veraltet
die aussicht das ist einfach
walter tänzer ist ein pionier der
vegetarischen und veganen bewegung ende
der 70er jahre schrieb der ökonom eine
dissertation über biologischen landbau
diese wurde abgelehnt zu radikal waren
seine vorstellungen über eine tier und
umweltfreundliche landwirtschaft in
seiner firma so jana die sich heute im
zürcherischen schlieren befindet stellte
er vor 34 jahren zum ersten mal tun
walter denn das ziel heute ist das
gleiche wie damals die erschaffung einer
rein pflanzliche lebensmittel welt und
sie probieren
plötzlich gemisch dann schmeckt das
natürlich sehr stark pflanzlich und des
königs bedürftig aber wenn sie jetzt die
ganze pflanzliche lebensmittel lassen
und noch einmal das milchprodukt ist was
schmeckt nach hohe stahl über 100
produkte aus biologischem getreide und
bio soja aus italien und frankreich
stellt so jana hier von toten über
pflanzlichen joghurt und sauerrahm bis
hin zum pflanzlichen frischkäse und
bewusster wird dann fragt er sich himmel
und was habe ich denn da vor mir
woher kommt das was hat was er macht ist
dass sich ist das wachsen der nati der
natur ist das immer
das sind vielleicht sogar dass das tier
gewartet und das ist ritter hat dass es
ein separates der tote nicht
und dann waren wir bewusster wird mir
das mit den ganzen ersparnissen seines
vaters eines einfachen fabrikarbeiters
kauf der waldenser 1981 seine erste
lieferung soja heute hat die so jana 40
angestellte dancers firma ist unabhängig
von den banken und finanziert sich zu
100 prozent über darlehen ihrer kunden
diese sind bereit für einen liter
getreide milch zwischen drei und knapp 4
franken zu bezahlen
die milchindustrie und mit bruder sind
der riesige beträge subventionen oder
auflöse zu fehlen viele jahre und
michael kann der autobahn im stau
wirklich gut und das heißt alles was ich
sehen die produktion haben wir als messe
für die jenen oder mit den hufen und
mietzins dafür zaubern
[Musik]
walter tänzer und sein team verschreiben
sich einem spirituellen weg zu einer
welt ohne tierleid auch heute noch
wilder dafür angefeindet
seine firma hafte sektenhafte es an er
hat der anspruch der einzige wagt sie
wozu seligkeit wird und das haben
überhaupt nicht mit sind spirituell
ausgerichtet die firma bedingung ist
dass jeder womit machenschaften und das
geht natürlich ein sehr schönes
harmonisches verhältnis unternehmen das
sind grün wohl nicht jede woche
mindestens aber zwei ehemaligen
überkommen bewältigen vorstellig sind
die der bank schaffte was ich wirklich
eine gute stellung und die sagen mir
geschrieben zusammen
ich hab schon freud nehme ich möchte sie
im vorjahr könnte mich irgendwie raus
stehen
jahrestreffen der motorrad brüder long
riders hier nahm daniel und corinna
pfisters veganes leben seinen anfang
[Musik]
gleich neben dem kriege schöpft chris
kohlbrenner sein veganer chelsea kam der
mit soja gehackten er war es der daniel
pfister durch seine vegane lebensweise
zum nach und umdenken brachte
schwer krank sie kurz vom druck standen
und die erfahrung dass eigentümer in
einem unter der kontrollen ist sondern
einfach in der hand vor analytik 2 auf
gedeih und verderb ausgeliefert ist das
ist ganz auf mich sehr sehr grenzwertige
erfahrungen und irgendein habe ich den
gedanken gemacht hat der vom künstler
der künstler habe mich bis zur
schlachtung von menschen nominiert
worden und habe ich sagen
eigentlich finden sich also mit deren
erfahrungen gemacht ist schon mehrfach
an dem aufgang
bei daniel pfister vielen chris cole
brennans gedanken auf fruchtbaren boden
er wurde veganer und steckte damit
seinen freund peter schick an sind
zusammen in den ferien und sie sind
bereits begonnen und sie ich bin
überzeugter fleischers demnach dass
unser ok es ist immer in den ferien noch
sehr viel vielleicht liegt das problem
und der hat ein kunde kann so probierte
gaddafi ausgeliefert wird schon mal
wissen was das soll hier befragten die
vertonte dass sie die liste vor den
ferien mit jenen vegan klasse und wir
sind ja ferien so verlagert hätten ist
noch nie so gut gegangen
am 1
veganer provozieren allein durch ihre
anwesenheit
sie hinterfragen bestehende
produktionssysteme und den umgang mit
unseren nutztieren
damit stellen sie die ganze gesellschaft
in frage
die soll das mache ich auch moderne das
ist das konsequent wäre die begonnen ist
auch oft fest jetzt mehr zeit im auto
muppets welche themen das nehmen wir
natürlich passiert das thema es ist mir
das abschlagen
seit diesem sommer ist vegane ernährung
ein thema in der politik
es geht um die initiative für
nachhaltige und fahrdynamik und im
bereich nachhaltige nerviges bis 1
verordnung bio oder genommen sondern
auch gange aber nur recht wenig vor
vegetarisch und vegan also plötzlich
obwohl für die studie zeige dass
eigentlich nichts vegetarisch und vegan
hielt mich an diese kontrakte
punkto tierschutz puncto umweltschutz
reagiert und der initiative fordert dass
in öffentliche kantine das vegetarische
angebot fördert und durst bietet wird
und das sollte gleich vegane option geht
dann haben sie einfach ihre emotionen
fleisch schon ja richtig und deswegen
als schweizer fleisch vom markt gekauft
obwohl es eigentlich aus brasilianischen
so verstellt war gewalt für abkauft
worten ich bin so gut die sache so
langsam alternative ist und vor allem 3
1 alex baumann setzte dort also was man
trägt
ich hab mal ein buch versucht aber hast
noch trüb
ich bin so gut ist auch dass sage wo
david wird dafür liegt wo wir gar nicht
raus doch eher schwierig sie wenn sie in
elements also habe ich es nicht so rosig
die sich vorstellen weg ins lager
manche sagen zu gern fleisch und
natürlich realistisch für mutter sharon
zum aktuellen zeitpunkt schon auf aber
mir weiß es vor fehlende historischer
wie spiele meine sachen wir pro
bestellung nach zum beispiel mehrmals
abgelehnt worden
bis 9 stößt
da gibt es viele beispiele und ich
glaube je früher desto schneller
hinter der initiative steht die gruppe
sentjens politics ein projekt der
giordano bruno stiftung schweiz eine
denkfabrik für humanismus und aufklärung
sentjens politik setzt sich ein für die
anliegen aller empfindungsfähigkeit für
mensch und tier puncto klimawandel hat
natürlich grafisch noch immer an unserem
fahrzeug das auf den elektrisch prozent
vor der emissionen bewohner verkleidung
20 arbeiten maßnahmen die politik das im
moment bin ich ohne auf den verkehr
konzentriert unglaublich sicher ein
wichtiger punkt visa aus hat sich dass
man nur durch stärke und dann einfach
lobt visconti fische zahlenmäßig punch
imperial in extremfällen spielstraße
durchschnittlicher fleisch konsumiert
und habe das itu zitiert also tierschutz
politisch sehr relevant und der unmenge
von co2 emissionen und würden dann bei
der extra fällig aber würde damit so
wenig eigentlich und wie nachlässig war
geschenkt noch damit die wette rennen
extrem verzicht auf tierische produkte
zu setzen
ja ich glaube das ist die aktuelle war
nahm ich mir das an dank bevor die sind
aber nicht sehr breite produktpalette
ist der steuerberater dachtest du
eigentlich überhaupt wasser
vernachlässigbare verzichtet und nach
wieder würde ich sagen aber es ist nicht
das außen und das ist nicht so schwarz
wie sie fragen sondern wenn wir zum
beispiel schon mal nach rindfleisch war
glatt
regionalität und das ja überhaupt nicht
des schwarz weiß sondern mit wenig
aufwand vom impact punkto umwelt also
wenn man sich anguckt um wie viel
prozent der co2 emissionen zucker oder
wie viel prozent weniger dir dass man
konsumiert und letztlich für die
initiative von zentrumspolitiker erhielt
adriano man ihn nur diesen frühling von
der gruppe ig freiheit den rostigen
paragraphen sie das dümmste gesetzt des
jahres oder glaube von ig freiheit will
ich habe meine freiheiten wenn man das
mainzer tormann dank dass also die ecke
die frau händigte dem mann mit der
nasenspitze dankbar ins herz das hatte
ich ja doch ein restaurant genauso hart
werk die diskussion mit den leuten und
andere in einem druck auf tele basel
erhält adriano mannino eine unerwartete
einladung die einladung zum besuch eines
schlachthauses journalisten dafür dass
man auch negativer chat und da fragen
sich natürlich der liebe zu der studie
[Musik]
machen wenig verschroben kann ich
überhaupt noch nie ist die junge was
muss ich jetzt da kochen was darauf viel
was darf wird als ich vor allem an den
klima gemerkt dass man sich damit
beschäftigt ist sehr spannend große haus
fertig ist zum spiel wir nachdem wir
nach sich die ganze familie sein und
traditionelle wieso nicht ein kocher ist
das erststudium losgegangen was koche
ich jetzt im himmel ist vieles muss hier
weg und wir handeln einen antritt auch
zu dir schnitt weg wir machen uns jetzt
den urlaub machen oder ganz mit einem
stand im internet kann wir recherchieren
das ist wie ein offenes buch und einen
kurzen moment als vorspiel sitzmann
ghoga mit knapp mit vier charlotte und
orangenöl grad das ist perfekt das ganze
bisher einfach und damit jetzt einfach
pilzrisotto gall und zum testen an die
mechanische krämer gemacht
drei generationen zwei sehr
unterschiedliche lebens- und
ernährungsweise
das klingt zwar wie geht's weiter
was ist mit ihnen ein kindergeburtstag
eingeladen ist was ist wenn sie findet
das andere wir nach zum ziel gemacht
sind eben auch noch gut schmecken später
wie sie den dank an kiosken wenn sie
meine bezahlt
alles was man verbietet ist ja sehr
attraktiv kleine kinder
ich weiß es noch nicht einmal zu
überdenken
die größer wird wird nicht immer sagen
heide durchschnitt das gibt dem
verrichtet jetzt konflikt weiß ich noch
nicht aber der wartung urlaub slk eatons
druck fürs kind entsteht aus dass ich
danke ganz wichtig oder wenn jetzt die
situation wird den stau in der schule
was used klasse wie die meeresbucht
hinein anders ein anderer mensch hearns
nur weil er anders ist und darum ist man
dann wirklich wenn es gravierend würde
die lehrer und eltern zu erziehen
einfach sagen sie ich sage danke alien
sich ganz normales kind wo hat einfach
mit mir nach fleischers sie stehen in
der lage und uns damit unserer lage ein
schlachthaus im basellandschaftlichen
geld erkennen
hierher bringt der bauer seine tiere
noch selber die anfahrtswege sind die
tiere stammen alle aus artgerechter
haltung
es ist sechs uhr in der früh
[Musik]
adriano mannino hat die einladung
angenommen die metzgermeister martin
zimmermann in jenem fernseh talk bei
tele basel ausgesprochen hat
[Musik]
moskau wiederum sich auf dem abstieg
klopft an den ebay es sich doch
irgendwie und das heißt der größte
respekt und anstand zu dienen und somit
umgang mit den medien
mit dem bolzenschuss wird das tier
lediglich betont
danach haben die metzger 20 bis 30
sekunden zeit das tier mit einem schnitt
durch die kehle ausbluten zu lassen
ergebnislose bvc ii so sie das denn
bewusst sei bis ausbreitet ist es immer
noch möglich dass das tier bewusst
sicher und dem ostallgäu damit das blut
relativ schmales erlaubt und ein auto
die tritt das team schmerzempfindlicher
florida das transport sich wo sind sie
und dann gab ich muss ich ihnen gewohnt
ist und dank in etwas groß sie
freundlich ja und verweist auf die
irgendwo auch die ungemein stark und
werden auch im raum dass am ende keine
berührungsängste oder verängstigt die
luftangriffe
die höhe
[Musik]
völlig normale ich würde das jetzt und
institutionalisiert ist dass es da
eigentlich passiert das ist es und da
konnte nach strand geworfen mit uns nach
zitiert organ für die rang zwei
ja
an diesem morgen werden hier in diesem
familienbetrieb 25 schweine geschlachtet
ihnen sind drei kälber und ein rind
vorangegangen pro jahr werden in der
schweiz laut proviant 64 millionen tiere
geschlachtet
die betreibung der schweine erfolgt mit
der electro zange nach dem ausbluten
werden sie geprüft und den tag
[Musik]
es ist extrem scheu historische
widersacher gesellschaft nachzusehen und
der mediengesellschaft xiii und will sie
nun mal sogar an ihre mitwirkung
hinterfragen würde abstrahierter das war
dass man mit dem ruftaxi ist uns noch
mal gesagt er glaube ich habe viel
weniger mir ist es als extremes problem
und auch stark verrußt dass wenn wir mit
seinen historischen abstand auf das
weitere nur dass meine hat er mit
anderen schreck auf das war gelogen hat
nein
die highlights dort findet ihr hier
normalerweise ist er und prallte
außerdem würde sagen dass der schaden
zufügen
dann sind wir schon dadurch natürlich
einfach braucht dort müsst ihr
top-niveau vom hersteller
denn dort man nicht ein video das
argumentieren die rau der sonderzüge und
mir ist das anders sein und nur dass die
regelung als eine weitere zone dann sind
ist das auch nur in begrenzter raum
aber wie sagte die st
90 wir sind jetzt vom thema geld sondern
sehr funktional verwandt fotograf hat zu
dem thema ein paar diskutierten cdu
wechselt aus darf man das überhaupt
nichts zeigt die beatles toten jener
dass man das nicht mehr aus münchen das
auf der art der gegner außer machen
wirtschaft aus es geht wie thor
breiteres argument ist traditioneller
wald bildet wenn das der mensch hier ich
brauche andere dir hier wusste schon
lange dass die materie china gehört und
die hat noch kein argument gerade von
ihrem und vorne
warum der mann einfach hier sagt corinna
und daniel pfister haben sich für diesen
weg und damit für ein veganes leben
entschieden
[Musik]
also setzt bessere meinen schon die
damenhandtasche entscheid getroffen und
die sps mit dampf angekündigt mit einer
gesünderen größer geschlafen
[Musik]